john
green un
bac la prof of work and
no
limit to your greg
richart a demandé ligue binding dreams
tune ans fred leighton min entre humour
troops and infrastructure management of
time
we are facing
sécurité
sécurité européenne nouvelles normes ou
la russie menacent l'ordre de sécurité
la russie utilise sa force pour
atteindre ces objectifs
tiendra la russie responsable pour ses
actions rochât
la russie est l'agresseur la biélorussie
et la biélorussie et le facilitateur
je suis la décision de poursuivre une
agression contre l'ukraine
est une énorme erreur stratégique
pour laquelle la russie aura un prix
lourd à payer au cours des années à
venir
l'union européenne et l'onu
ont mis en place des sanctions sévères
de nombreux partenaires du monde entier
nous ont rejoints dans ces sanctions oui
nous devons être prêts à en faire
davantage
même si cela signifie pour nous que cela
a pris
car cette crise est prise au long terme
parallèlement à cela le peuple russe
doit savoir
que la guerre du kremlin contre
l'ukraine
ne donnera pas davantage de sécurité al
arich cette guerre
ne donnera pas davantage de respect de
considération à la russie dans le monde
dans le monde et cette guerre ne
conduira pas un meilleur futur meilleur
ou renforcement militaire de la russie
des
de ces derniers mois nous avons augmenté
la capacité de défense hier ses alliés
de l'otan ont activé leurs plans de
défense
nous sommes donc en train de déployer
des éléments de la force de réaction de
l'océan sur terre sur mer et dans les
airs
il s'agit de renforcer nos positions
et d'être en mesure de réagir rapidement
à tout type de développement et
d'évolution les etats unis le canada et
les alliés européens
ont déployé des milliers de troupes au
sol dans la partie orientale et sud
oriental de l'alliance
nous avons eu deux cents avions sont en
alerte opérationnelle
depuis près de trente pages
20 bâtiments sont déployés 120 bâtiments
sont déployés de la baltique à la
méditerranée
ainsi avec des capacités d'emport
d'avion
il
ne doit pas y avoir de malentendu de la
part de la russie nous ferons ce qui est
nécessaire pour défendre chacun des
alliés et chaque pouce de territoire des
pays de l'otan
les deux
dirigeants ont dit très clairement
aujourd'hui que nous devons continuer à
soutenir l'ukraine
de couper ce soutien
notre réponse que l'équipe doit donc
être en conséquence sans apporter
davantage des comptes des pays comme la
moldavie la géorgie et la bosnie
herzégovine en particulier adams oxydes
afin de les aider à conduire leur
réponse démocratique
et de poursuivre le chemin qu'elles ont
choisie c'est que ces pays ont choisi
aujourd'hui plus que jamais cette crise
démontre l'importance
de l'unité dans l'otan de la mer du nord
et de l'europe il n'y a pas de sécurité
en europe sans un lien transatlantique
je suis maintenant prêt à répondre à vos
questions
quelles sont vos craintes cantal quant
au fait que tu tombes
à votre avis comment le gouvernement
imaginons qu'on une situation où une
situation de tir guérilla et
insurrection ces quelques le soutien de
l'otan il y à une invasion de grande
ampleur de toute l'ukraine depuis
différents axes attaque avec soutien
aérien et maritime et des forces
terrestres et c'est tout à fait ce
qu'ils avaient prévu nos services de
renseignements sur le long terme car
nous avons vu la montée en puissance des
capacités
autour de l'ukraine avec des forces
terrestres maritimes et aériennes nous
avons constaté les mouvements versier et
nous avons également perçu
la rhétorique et les messages envoyés
[Musique]
indiquant que l'objectif était
de changer le gouvernement ukrainien
d'en retirer le gouvernement
démocratiquement élu nous sommes en lien
étroit bien sûr avec le gouvernement qui
craignent un
jeu suivant de très près la situation
sur le terrain
une situation qui n'est toujours pas
fixée
les ukrainiennes se bat avec grande
bravoure
sont en capacité infliger 2 des pertes
importantes aux forces d'invasion
mais une fois encore je tiens à dire
c'est une situation qui n'est pas encore
fixée situation qui qualifierait de
fluides et qui évolue en permanence les
alliés de l'otan exprimée
dans le cadre de ce sommet
qu'ils étaient prêts à
porter leur soutirent à l'ukraine un
soutien militaire financier humanitaire
je pense
qu'il faudra apprécier la situation
suite aux évolutions à venir
avec le soutien est également celui de
la floride 2 et de la suède le soutien
est en cours depuis plusieurs années il
se poursuivra et est-ce qu'on a changé